There are many things that can sabotage you at a job interview.
A swearword tattooed across your knuckles,...
...drunken karaoke videos on your MySpace page...
...or having ever worked for hotnewz.
Just kidding.
But one you may not be aware of is your body language.
Greg Hartley, author of Body Language Expert, explains.
About 85% of everything you say is not with words.
It's with the tone of your voice,...
...with your body language, with how you sit, with the way you look at someone.
When you go to a job interview, one of the first things to remember...
...is the younger you are, the more energy you are liable to have.
And that energy will lead through things called adaptors.
For those of us who aren't up on our body language lingo, adaptors means fidgeting.
You might pull your neck if it's a woman or if it's a guy you may wring your hands or rub your thighs...
...and that's the release of energy that shows that you are uncomfortable.
You need to learn to mask those.
So remember, if you're squirming more than a two-year-old watching Seize band,...
...they may not want you to manage the big account.